Speaker 1: So we're continuing our discovery
for lack of a better term of who did what, who
knew what, who tried what. In the lead up to the
November of 2020 election in the period between
the November election and the Jan. six riots and
then after the Jan. six riots to try to cover up
what was done, tried, said and attempted during
that previous period of time. And a lot of the
stuff we're learning, we're learning thanks to the
work of this House Select Committee investigating
the Jan. six riots in the next segment. We're
going to have some incredible revelations
from Republican Republican Congresswoman
Liz Cheney. But before we get to that,
we are now getting a list of documents from
the House Committee. We don't yet or won't have
all of the content of each of these documents.
But what we know so far is, I mean, chilling and
disturbing is probably an understatement. Listen
to this chilling Trump letter calling for seizure
of election material revealed in log to January
6th probers. The letter was created a day before
Trump discussed naming conspiracy theorist
Sidney Powell, special counsel, to probe
baseless election fraud claims. The document in
question and you can find this is there's a PDF
and I'm putting it up on the screen. You can find
this. This is publicly available, mixed in with
a whole bunch of other documents which may or may
not be interesting to you. There is an item called
Draft Poultice Letter, meaning a draft letter from
Trump. And it says it is described as draft letter
from Potosi to seize evidence in the interest
of national security for the 2020 elections. Now
there are a few interpretations of what this could
be, and they're all absolutely terrifying. Let's
go back to this Huffington Post article, which
outlines a bunch of it. The log, along with a
trove of documents, was provided last week. They
were handed over by Trump ally Bernie Kerik,
former NYPD commissioner and confidante of Rudy
Giuliani. Kerik was a key adviser to Trump's legal
team, trying to cook up a narrative of fraud in
the presidential election that Joe Biden won.
Besides the documents, Kerik turned over. He also
offered a log of documents he refused to provide,
including the Trump letter. Among the documents
withheld is one described as draft letter from
police to seize evidence in the interest
of national security in the 2020 election.
Though Trump ultimately didn't take
action to seize election materials,
such a letter could be a key piece of information
in the investigation into Trump's strategy to
undermine a legitimate election. Authorities have
found no evidence of fraud. The letter was created
Dec. 18. That's the day before he met with General
Flynn and others to try to figure out what to do.
Trump also discussed naming far right attorney
conspiracy theorist Sidney Powell as special
counsel. He ultimately didn't do that. Flynn
had already suggested Trump could invoke
martial law to seize control of the
election. Remember, this is the guy who
wanted to review voter registrations
nationally, right? That's one idea Trump
floated. I believe it was in advance of the
midterms. This is not someone who considers
sacred information related to people's actual
voting, and what it means sees information is
not even exactly clear. But it's extraordinarily
authoritarian. You know, we talked earlier.
All of these right wingers say when Twitter banned
Marjorie Taylor Greene for COVID disinformation,
when Twitter banned Dr. Robert Malone for COVID
disinformation, that's authoritarian fascism. No,
it's not. It's a private business enforcing terms
of service in a completely legal way. On the other
hand, when a sitting president drafts a letter
saying Let's seize election materials, which
could be a mail in ballots, it could be voting
machines. It could be all sorts of different
things. Let's seize it and try to use it to steal
the election, which was, of course, the goal
that in and of itself deserves an investigation.
That is the authoritarian nightmare that these
right wingers say Twitter is actually doing. When
we now understand the context of all of this,
which was trying to do an insurrection coup. What
exactly did Trump and his legal team plan on doing
with the voting data? Even the guy Trump
put in charge? Remember that whole committee
that you might have forgotten about it because it
found nothing, but I think it was called the Voter
Integrity Commission or committee or something. He
put that guy, Kris Kobach, the Kansas secretary of
State, in charge of it. It found nothing. Even he
wasn't willing to seize the voter information back
during that period or wasn't willing. Maybe just
realized it wouldn't work. Right? And as I was
reading all of this over the weekend, I don't know
how many of you saw the recent film. Don't look up
with Leonardo DiCaprio and Jennifer Lawrence and
a bunch of other actors. It feels much more like
a documentary than satire. The more we read about
what this administration was doing towards towards
the very end, the honestly the the most. So there
may be a spoiler here. There may be a spoiler.
There may be a spoiler about the film. Don't look
up. The most unrealistic part of Don't Look Up
was that some people actually changed their minds
once they saw the comet with their own eyes,
Trumpists would have claimed. Even looking at
the comment, you can't believe that you can only
believe what Trump says. It must be a Soros
founded projection that looks like a comment
meant to scare us into accepting government
control or whatever. I mean, that's how weaponized
this disinformation has become. And as we learn
about all of the things they almost tried,
it makes it even more urgent that we put in
safeguards so that they can't even get this going
in 2024. And we've talked about that
earlier. We're going to talk about it again.